well the rangers trying to win the
series today against seattle season
numbers for dane dunning this will be
his seventh start of the season for the
rangers great strikeout to walk ratio 29
strikeouts seven walks for him that is
in 28 in the third inning so far this
season and the pitch is swung on in this
gotta be the sliders down the mound
young left-hander justice sheffield
two and two on the year with a four
point one eight era getting ready for
his sixth start of the year
and so isaiah off to a good start
on this mother's day
and this one served in the left field
base hit by low
what a good piece of hitting kind of
stops at second
rangers have a couple of base runners
good thing turning double players one
rackham
[Applause]
and on time again the double play has
been very very good to the mariners
oh and he strikes out more looking to
start things in the second
nice picture from dame dunning fastball
that is away two seemed fast full so
it's got a little bit of movement coming
back and a perfect freeze
for a called third strike one two pitch
from dunning oh right down the middle
strike three called
back-to-back strikeouts in the second
well that two-seat basketball looks like
it's got a little bit of life on it
jumping on some of these mariners
hitters who have not been able to pull
the trigger two two pitch swing and a
miss he struck you now
got him on a slider three strikeouts in
the inning for dane dunning
see what happens oh two
breaking ball swinging a miss two down
first strikeout for chef here's another
slider you can see murphy had his glove
on the ground he wanted in a bury it
gets away with it he's kind of getting
on the outside of it staying on that
plane end up in the middle of the plate
02. here's the stretch by sheffield
checks the runner at second
the o2 pitch backdoor slider a swing
animus for strike three so sheffield
striking out culverson and that'll end
the ending a couple of strikeouts for
justice
02 pitch
and a swing and a miss
fifth strike out of the ball game
and not another slider out of the zone
we talked about this with dane dunning
and his ability to generate these chases
and swings and misses
and that is a perfectly executed back
foot slider as we call it right-handed
pitcher down and in
to a lefty and a pretty ugly swing
from jp crawford
1-2
and a swing and a miss
six strikeouts through three innings
for dame dunny hey here we go
swinging a miss that's a better slider
that's where he wanted to locate the
slider bury it one two count
that's what we're looking for at least
push him a little bit here early that's
a hard ground ball third senior couldn't
get it cleanly and he'll have no play
that thought on him in a hurry
and connor felefa is on
double play depth up the middle
and solac rolls this one up the middle
but it goes off the glove of more
everybody's safe and it will go down as
an error and
it doesn't quite do justice to how big a
play that could be
strike three called two down fourth
strikeout for sheffield first one
against the top of the order and here's
the cleanup hitter adolesce garcia kicks
and fire
swinging a line drive left center field
base hit for garcia
tyner falefa around 30s in the score the
throw goes into second rbi single
adolesce garcia rangers lead one nothing
that's nice to see garcia come through
again do it in front of these ranger
fans they have watched him on television
and now they are seeing the real deal
here in person not a bad pitch at all
watch where this is located away little
backdoor slider
garcia goes out and gets it maybe even
off the plate a little bit
[Applause]
and they get somebody hung up
between home and third let's see how
they execute
that's low
jp better speed ends it right there
i remember last time i saw that
one two pitch
and a swing and a miss barely got
started with the swing but he couldn't
stop it and that's a seventh strikeout
for dunning
now the swinging strike three that's the
eighth strikeout for dunning and he's
locked in
two and two over shift on three on the
right side now pitch to trammell struck
him out swinging on a slider
strikeout number nine a new career high
for dane dunning and a new season high
for any rangers pitcher a couple of men
aboard from mitch hanigar
goes the other way that gets it by nate
lowe gallo will retrieve
evan white coming around to score we
need a tie ball game with 1-1
25th run batted in for mitch haniger and
this is a situation where mitch was not
going to pull off the slider this time a
late swing on the fastball i think he
was just kind of sitting in between that
fast ball middle in elevated form
[Applause]
did he go
yes he did and that is strike three the
tenth
strike out of the ball game
and downing the first rangers pitcher to
get double digits and strikeouts this
year so two on and two outs
the go go-ahead run still on at third
base in crawford and that'll bring up
kyle sager
slow roller
counter philipe has got no play
jp crawford scores and the mariners have
a 2-1 lead
siege with an rbi didn't get it out of
the infield still put it in the
cha-ching column i think he catches a
little bit of a break culberson a
strikeout victim his first time up with
a runner at second two outs in the
second we'll lead off the bottom of the
fifth
culverson first pitch swinging high in
the air to the left
just like that
we're tied up at two
well all that work for
the seattle mariners to scratch across
those two runs and just like that the
lead goes away
on one pitch and one swing from charlie
culverson so nick solac is having a
really nice year and doing some pretty
big damage against fastballs the 1-1
[Applause]
he'll score standing
a two-run double by solace and the
rangers lead four to two
and right on time the slugging continues
for nick solac and this time
in a really big spot fifth double of the
season for him he's gonna get a two-seed
fastball and a nice moment here for
garcia we know that he loves
the big moments
sheffield delivers again and that ball's
hit high in the air
deep up to left center that one is gone
well and thank goodness the dolis has
learned how to hit here at home
got a great series in minnesota it's
carried over here to this series against
the mariners
[Applause]
has done it again
two strike pitch
and that's on the ground up the middle
base hit and culverson
really swinging a hot bat
and he has a board to start things in
the sixth inning 100 from mills and this
one into right field that's a base hit
culverson charging from first heads to
third base slides in there safely on the
base hit by trevino
great base running again from charlie
culverson
that one on the first baseline great
play by white
to touch the base and then throw to
second for the double play but culverson
races in from third and the rangers
steal a run it's eight to two he had
assisted on conor felefer
what a great play by evan white
another right-handed hitter inside out
swing on another fastball that was in on
him
adolesce garcia last three home games
including today now 5 45 average with a
couple of bombs and six driven in
[Applause]
hard out to center field base hit it
gets so lagged to the plate
five rbis for adolesce garcia and the
rangers lead 9-2 he is just absolutely
feeling it right now is adolesce garcia
and the damage continues this looks like
a fastball it is right down the middle
not a lot of movement at all on that
fastball and garcia came into this one
with an ops over a thousand against
fastballs from right-handed pitchers so
the damage continues the numbers go up
two and two and here's the pitch and the
bouncing ball slowly hit the third that
will score a run
sieger the first got him with a big
stretch by white out toward right field
but solace picks up an rbi
taps this one up the middle
kind of philippa has it the pirouette
the throw in time
and this one is over a little razzle
dazzle from kinder philetha to finish it
off
and the rangers are back to 500 at 18
and 18.